let me bring in cam Jordan who joins us
now the Saints defense event that's a
bummer about Zion Williamson are you
basketball fan cam oh yeah you know I
some would say I'm a sons fan first in
the pelicans fan second but yeah
hey it's trippy have you met Zion yeah a
couple times you know you can talk about
getting drafted number one overall and
you know we share the same parking lot I
see him from time to time what position
does it look like he would play in the
NFL defensive in the best position is he
bigger than you I'm taller for sure yeah
probably six six six seven six six 285 I
mean I feel like I know what six six is
like he feels like successes well no
they measured him they are actually
measuring NBA players this year cuz guys
have been lying about their height for
such a long time uh yeah you know can we
get the same thing that happened for
football I mean I feel like naturally
though the NFL Combine guys somehow get
like an extra inch and a half and I want
to know how that happened
well Brees was 6 1 & a half I thing for
a long time I mean he's 6 feet tall
right and they say kylie Marie's 510
again I don't know where the guys get
about this Internet 2 inches oh well you
got Kyler Murray coming up how do you
simulate facing Kyler Murray I don't
know in terms of practice I think we're
gonna let we might we might have to let
album come are you no no go be quite a
bit but I mean in terms of shittin it
Kylie's collar is explosive now coming
up to pockets and presses in fact in
terms of in terms of you know what he's
able to do he's a baller I might even
let jayante Harris get it because they
may be the same size did you watch
Monday Night Football
yeah I want some bits and pieces of it I
mean Monday night was a date night for
us we had a TV go on so we were out
there of watching this the capsizing of
the Jets
what is it like you know as you watch
the Patriots thank you they make it seem
sort of simple but it it can't be that
simple can you explain what the Patriots
do when rocky I mean you're hearing
you're out there clearly the best team
in AFC East and I mean I'd like to say
buffa was gonna put pressure on them but
that's clearly not going to happen and
then you know between the Miami Dolphins
and the Jets is that is it two wins
between the two of them one way yeah
they beat the Cowboys ah okay yeah but
but I'm watching Sam darn 'old and Sam
darn old after the game even during the
game said he was seeing ghosts what does
that mean to you yeah I'm gonna leave
that alone maybe that's maybe that's a
quarterback thing and maybe that
suggests thing I don't I don't even know
how to answer that's not a good thing
though cam if your quarterback is seeing
ghosts yeah didn't you try to even
explain that no I don't know if anybody
asked him because that's what I wanted
to I said did anybody go hey Sam what's
that mean you were seeing ghosts I'm
guess he's seeing probably 14 Patriots
on defense that that would be my guess
yeah maybe he couldn't pick where you
know maybe there were only say Q's were
they disguise daddies as well maybe he's
got some lingering you know mono I don't
know
is Brees ready to come back do you think
he's gonna play in this game
that's a very Drew Brees Sean Peyton
question is when do come back drew comes
back and when he went and healthy and
ready to gun-sling you know we see him
take all the shadow practice rest the
dough strips
as far as you know this team went when
Brees went down and Teddy's stepped up
what did what was the locker room like
what what what did anything change
anything yeah I mean for the first time
in you know my career here we were you
know drew stayed out in LA for his voice
I was waiting for the team for like a
week that was first time you didn't see
that man you know be the first one in
and when the last guys leave but in
terms of what the locker room is I mean
I feel like we've come gelled even
closer as a defense as a team because we
know that you know if anybody has our
backs it's got to be us and especially
when Drew first went down and we lost to
the rounds outside looking in you know
everybody was from you know all the
analysts were talking negatively about
how we probably weren't going to succeed
but we know that you know the locker
room we have you know the integrity of
the guys that we have in this locker
room and it was up to us to you know
prove the world wrong and I feel like
later six games later five games later
yeah we're doing all right
he's cam Jordan the Saints defensive end
four-time Pro Bowler and first-team
all-pro in 2017 seven sacks through
seven games so far if I could give you a
mulligan and we just took away now I
know that you never take away from the
non call against the Rams but the fact
that because of that because of one call
we changed reviewing pass interference
if if you could take that away and like
is it solved anything is it made the
game any better I don't know that's
unless you speculate on that because at
this point you know I just I've seen it
I've seen the flag been thrown a couple
of times it has it gone their way so I
have no idea we talked about what it is
to actually throw the flag or impact the
game I know there has been flag that
work you know there was donor Lee that
uh you know some air flags that have
been thrown they'll be taken away a
touchdown
well you know my suggestion cam is
instead of having all-star officiating
crews in the postseason you should have
you should reward the team you know of
officials that work during the regular
season therefore I think that those guys
would have asked for help or somebody
would have interjected and said you know
what you missed that and you know what
let's let's
you know huddle up here and get that
call right it felt like because they
were all-star crew that maybe ego got
involved in that what do you think of my
conspiracy theory
you know it had been about seven months
ago I would have entertained every
conspiracy theory but at this point you
know we're on to a new season we're on
to what we've got you know we've got
ahead of us yeah as much as we talk
about those zebra stripes ooh that is
that is something that you know we just
hopefully expect for a higher standard
you know like an answer and I wonder I
guess the only thing that leaves that
permanently in your rear-view mirror is
winning a Super Bowl then it's then it's
never then it's rarely brought up would
you say yeah you know I feel like if we
win a Super Bowl I mean that that makes
you know the last two years of playoffs
mishaps better I mean in terms of icing
in a Nino stereotype we got Aaron
Rodgers on later on in the show I think
he was at Cal but five years six years
before you did you ever cross paths with
Aaron Rodgers in oh no yeah no tangled
on the field a couple times yeah yeah
after the game of course he's older than
me I wouldn't say significantly older
but he's definitely over you know and
especially you know we go to the
prestigious university like be universal
in your buzzer it's always it's always
ties there you know it's always familiar
there's always crowd that you couldn't
rely on you know the go bears we're a
long you Bears goes far you don't have a
secret handshake do you I wish would you
would you ease up on Rodgers just a
little bit no you would not you know I
like to hit I'd like to hit all my
friends the further conversation in the
offseason you know if I can smack all of
my friends need to talk about it
how many quarterbacks do you have his
friends who are not on the sings that's
a phenomenal question you know I like
Jameis I actually like Jameis off the
field you know I feel like me and Cam
Newton have a special bond but
[ __ ] or not that's a bromance I think
from your perspective maybe not from
cams it might be one-sided I feel like
you know I've got I've got nothing but
the deepest appreciation from that Ryan
I don't know something about these NFC
quarterback innocence all quarterbacks
is they hold a special place for me
could you see wearing a bonnet like
Camden you know a special interpretation
of fashion I don't think many people in
this world could pull that off
but maybe he can big that's a pole that
I will take part of how about the next
time you play them you were weird even
by when I don't ask my eyes maja to you
about it but also I asked Greg Olson
about this I said this does Cam Newton
have a if we win outfit and if we lose
that because it's tough to go to that
press conference after you've lost and
you're dressed like that you got a
bonnet on do you have a win and a lose
outfit no no I don't either
no he doesn't know that's what Greg
Olson said he goes no no that what he
shows up with that's it and there are
times when he loses and I go that's not
a good look for a guy who just got blown
out you know maybe it's like the big bad
wolf scheme maybe he just has like a
basket of muffins or something along
with it after you know they win maybe he
just leaves that best maybe there's
something accessories that we're missing
after a win versus a lot no no no I
think they're being nice to cam but uh I
understand it you know you want to keep
the peace and that's your that's your
guy your boy you see you send him wine
he doesn't send wine to you you send
wine to him I was trying to share the
celebration oh wow we'll leave it at
that
have fun Jason Kilar Murray this weekend
and always great to talk to you Congrats
started the season absolutely it's a cam
Jordan one of our favorite Saints
defensive end four-time Pro Bowler and
first-team all-pro in 2017
seven sacks through seven games yeah he
sends Cam Newton wine I think whenever
they win they beat them then he sends
Cam wine I guess if you're that big you
can get away with that for more Dan
Patrick show tune in to audience Channel
239 on DirecTV stream for free on BR
live or download the Dan Patrick show
app
[Music]